but to pat's point right now look that
sounds well and good and you know and
for for the record i hold xrp so i hope
it does 5x but right now it's like 75
cents correct so you're not talking
about 250 billion you're talking like 40
billion all right and the us government
has nothing but money in time so from
the outside looking in i'm not an
attorney but if this looks frivolous
this looks like somebody's trying to
lean on somebody this looks like maybe i
don't know you know like you said
moneygram western union decided to get a
couple senators in there and say you
know this is going to put us completely
out of business like we make 25 we make
25 cents out of every dollar transferred
these guys can do this instantaneously
for no money like get rid of these guys
uh
but
what's to say that they don't just keep
dragging it out dragging it out dragging
it out dragging them out bleeding you
out bleeding you out i mean how long can
they they take this if they take this
thing 10 years
is ripple going to fight for 10 years
what's what's their breaking point
before they say okay you know what fine
where security closed the thing down
reincorporated mexico with this same
exact white paper and start over it's a
great question the
my settlement scenario was if
that pressure point existed for ginsler
that it was going to you know put them
on a business regulating all the other
crypto because of the precedent if those
rulings don't come down favorable for
ripple then i don't think there's a
settlement i think it goes to verdict
and i think it's on appeal and i think
we are looking at a couple years of that
process at some point ripple could tap
out and say listen we'll we'll go with a
certain uh designation we can only sell
to accredited investors now you know
there's ways to get around it but i
don't see it happening i i see it either
settling you know
because of those rulings that come down
or
it goes to verdict and there was a
verdict in connecticut not too long ago
where a jury came back where there was a
digital asset a small one
where they uh the jury said that's not
an unregistered security and so
um
that's where i think we're headed
so let me go back to that though let me
go back to that because the point was we
have two things settle
and dismiss right
you almost want settlement more than you
want to be dismissed right because if
they dismiss it
then that means hey we're coming back
again and again and again and again and
again right so there's a part of
brad and chris and the 62 thousand and
it's 62 000 you're representing but
there's more xrp of course so what's the
number 456 i i saw a number like 450 500
000 xrp holders something some number
like that right so
so if they if they dismiss
and they don't do anything what happens
then
then we have this cloud
hanging over us and what gerard said i
think you had when you had kurt i was
watching that video when you had kurt
yeah and and and gerard summed up the
unfortunate nature of what's happening
in this country he literally said
um ripple was similar to bitcoin they
were just dumb enough to do it in the
united states
i mean that that sums it up we'll be
right there where there'll be this
uncertainty and right now you have gary
gensler saying come in and talk to us
come in and talk to us as soon as they
they're using those interviews as a
way to learn information about the
company as soon as you leave by time you
get to your office you have a subpoena
uh brian armstrong of coinbase was
trying to negotiate with them over that
lin product and all of a sudden he
shares with him all that information he
goes in and he talks to him and then
what do they say if you bring that lin
product we're going to sue you
why do you think they did want to be the
first to to incorporate the united
states they're obviously not dumb guys
why do you think they want they wanted
this fight i feel like i feel like they
kind of maybe not the sec maybe not the
way that they've gone after it but i
feel like they poked the bear you know
by by
kind of swinging against the current and
i don't know maybe they thought they
would skip the line and be the first
that would become like some sort of
you know state-backed you know uh you
know as eb tucker called it fedcoin
right i don't know what what their what
the intention was i don't know what kind
of conversation you have with them but
but have they ever described to you what
their thinking was with making this you
know an american product no i i've never
never spoken to them you know and a lot
of a lot of my critics will say oh you
know he's a plant for ripple look what
he's doing never spoken to him um there
was a report done by fox business on
this story and they said deaton's no
fanboy of ripple i don't got anything
against him i'm an xrp holder i want
them to be successful because if they're
successful the whole ecosystem grows but
but i don't know why a lot of people ask
that question so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]